everybody knew that Donald Trump's
incentive was I want America to be a
nice place for Americans I don't care
about you and they said okay so Russia's
like well I'm not gonna need to invade
if if the U.S is pushing for NATO
expansion anymore and then with the way
they frame it in the corporate press
here is Donald Trump was doing Putin's
bidding why because his bidding was he
didn't want a NATO country bordering
like every every border country to be a
NATO country that was one of those
missed opportunities was we could have
made a frenemy out of Russia because
they needed it they didn't have China
yet now we screwed that up okay we made
an enemy out of what was an enemy let's
be clear Putin was always going to be an
enemy but you can make deals with
enemies now he's making a deal with our
actual enemy who's actually capable of
taking us on on the global stage and
we're on the sidelines you know it's
horrifying